hello everyone thank you for sending
that long line and well the weather is
beautiful today but I really appreciate
it hi my name is Chi hun cha i'm a
business development manager in google
play in my daily job I work with Korean
developers based in Seoul and internally
I lead a team of other BDS to help you
guys do more better in yer go global
efforts more focused on ass in this
session I will talk about the
opportunities of the APEC market
especially focusing on Japan Korea
Southeast Asia you saw it on the title
but we're all will be also talking about
Taiwan and Hong Kong and we will talk
about the users in that market also
about experiences from other developers
success stories and the tips and Google
tools that you can go back home and
start implementing right away so I'm not
the first one telling you this but
Google Play is truly a global platform
and you can reach almost anywhere in the
world with Google Play I would like to
start with a coat that I really love we
here at developers say that Google Play
has fundamentally changed the way how
they do business and in the case of
smart study the CEO gave this wonderful
coat they open doors through play but
went on beyond play to their to maybe to
youtube and to retail presence and so on
so Google Play just was the trigger to
expand their business globally it's like
I don't know if you know this animation
there's a Japanese character who has
this magical door where he opens it he
can basically enter any place that he
wants to go I feel that Google Play is
that door for you you could open and go
into any
circuit that you want to go and today
we're going to open the markets to AIPAC
the asian market is the single largest
market that we have on play according to
app any the countries that I will cover
today japan korea taiwan hong kong in
Southeast Asia they make the fifty
percent of total revenue in the mobile
app business that's basically the half
of the market so does this portion
resonate with your business no yes I
know if it doesn't if this may mean this
much more opportunity of your business
to grow not only a peg is all about
revenue it's about huge growth and
install base again according to have any
we see that the instigate especially in
Southeast Asia is fifty-four percent
higher than that of the global average
it's really a great growth that we're
seeing in these APEC markets but the
reality is not that easy it's not rosy
how many of you know all the games that
you see on the screen it's a it's a
screenshot that I took from Korea and
top crossing chart ranking yesterday do
you recognize the games anyone well as
you can see there aren't many global
titles that you easily recognized from
let's move on to Japan it's I took it on
the same day do you see any duplicate
can you recognize it's kind of difficult
right I actually there is one and not a
lot of global titles again what this
means is local developers are really
dominating these markets so a really
tough competition there
does this sound like a barrier does this
discourage you well we think that one of
the human errors that we easily make is
we make conclusions too fast even we
don't know the full information to base
up that conclusion so today let's talk
about what would be the key levers to
move the needles in a pack markets and
let's have it and take it on your
business and really explore together
what could work better for you so what
makes it so different before I go into
the details let me ask you a quick
question how many of you are game
developers raise your hand okay a little
less than I expected how many of you are
non game developers app developers great
okay and some of you are just in between
that's good if you're starting and
you've you're kidding that's still fine
there is the old Asian Confucius saying
that if three people walk together at
least one of them is my teacher meaning
if it doesn't directly meet applies to
your business take a learning from their
understand what is behind that logic and
take it into your business we can learn
from as developers can learn from games
games can also learn from apps so let's
do that let's have that mindset together
so on the very basic when we talked
about going global very easy pitfalls
that developers fall into would be they
think it's okay enough to build an app
that works well on their country which
which could be making sense because you
know if you're just going to the local
market that's fine but if you're going
to the global market this is totally a
different story you have to be aware
that infrastructure is very much
different connectivity device and even
with the mature market the device my
situation might be very much different
for example I'm from Korea Koreans love
big screens we call them phablets and
the economy could be different even if
the market seems good the purchasing
power of users are different and
sometimes even though all these other
technical scene seemed okay content
policy could be something that could
hold your service from really going into
that market and at market size itself
and the maturity of the amp market is
one of the things that you should
consider before going global but I'm not
going to go into details on this because
we have a wonderful session coming right
after this it's building for billions
happening on stage 5 so after this if
you're interested in more in building
for emerging markets go to stage 5 and
check that that so back to what makes
asian different we just love different
characters and we love the characters in
a way a little bit different from
Western culture of course there are
loyal fans of characters everywhere but
in Asia it's more like it's in debt
better to our lives this is an example
of Pokemon game from the pokemon company
and as you can see just imagine from the
structure the game itself is something
that you might you know easily under
what the logic is but this game is a hit
and the users love it because they love
the Pokemon and another difference
between Western and Eastern is about the
high context culture this may have
started from Chinese characters having a
lot of conveying a lot of meanings in
single words this is mixes monster
strike and their promotional images from
on the left side Japan on the right side
global this is so apparent difference
right for Japanese users if you give
them the screen on the right they would
feel like something is missing or this
is foreign but it's on the Western eyes
if you see the image on the left side
you will look like oh they need a
designer so keep that in mind and I want
you to pay a close attention to this
part the live operation have any of you
heard about the live operation raise
your hand if you have oh good yeah I
will take simple examples of life
operations to give you an idea it's
basically a stage of app that evolves
with the user interaction one of the
easy an early stage of live operation
will be live chatting with users through
Game Master AKA GMS I game developer so
you would know what it is you have
accounts within the game and a chatting
system within the game and game masters
reaches out to users asking you know I
think you're enjoying this game but you
could even enjoy this game even more if
you do this or they get their feedback
like somebody would say well this game
is getting kind of boring after stage 43
and then the game master could
understand and take that and implement
it in a way that could be more
interesting to users it's a very good
way of engaging with the users recently
the successes we have seen a live
operation is the collaboration with the
eyepiece this is again as an example for
a mixes monster strike
a partner with Japan's long loved
character Evangelion and they took the
world of Evangelion and placed it in the
game and users they just loved it and
this is what keeps the users engaging
and keeps new user inflow even though
game has been up there for more than
several months and live operations are
doing events at the right moment at the
right time you see this is a revenue
graph from an actual developer based in
Korea and Japan and you see a lot of
spikes that is not usual for other
markets in this is because we have
direct carrier billing which has a cap
that refreshes on the first day of the
month so people are now they have a
budget that they can spend more on and
as you can see the spike gets even
bigger and bigger because developers who
really do the ripe operations right take
the moment and give the best of events
and promotions that users cannot say no
to and it's the time where they have a
willingness to pay full willingness to
pay a good example would be in the
marble future fight I love this game
I've been having so much time finding
what the characters I love in this game
they had a promotion on the Black Friday
you might have done similar stuffs
already and they announced with a really
nice deal and they saw eight hundred and
sixty-nine percent increase in revenue
compared to the previous day and which
means they're creating the spikes and in
a game if you want to keep the life
lifetime of the game longer and longer
these spikes are really necessary to
keep the revenue going it means that
users are engaging back to your service
or game so what I told you was about the
differences between somewhat Western and
Eastern cultures now I will talk about
even more differences among the APEC
countries so this is the icon screenshot
of Japan and Korea can you feel the
difference yeah so in our team you would
say if they don't have a nose it's
Japanese icon if they have a nose and
it's a woman and they're very slim and
beautiful it's usually Korean so there's
a the users like different type of
images and they even like different type
of game plays for Korean it's more about
pvp meaning 101 battles and for Japan
it's not that people don't enjoy PvP
it's like it's more like Japanese users
prefer collaborated play a little more
so to give you a better idea let me show
you and it's a good clips of their TV
commercials showing this different
this is Korean game Navarro got
addiction
can you compare one ed Reed & Johnson
mr. Cooper
stylish direction I just some day Lisa
you are in cone so the video is very
much focused on single person right and
let's take a look at mix sees TV
commercial now you see a lot of people
to begin
Indian culture of much in the chase
festival within the game to show that
this is sort of a game that you can take
the feeling of mastery into your phone
and experience that collaborate a play
so it is so different even among the
apac market so what you have to do no
I'm not trying to discourage you what I
have fun I'm trying to tell you is you
need to understand there could be even
more differences in the market where you
don't know and if you explore a little
more you'll be able to see and pick up
this kind of little subtle differences
that works well in these markets let's
explore what you can actually do better
in a pit markets I'll try to break down
into four sections first three is more
like a process you have to understand
your market planet and go and second we
will talk about how to better localize
the app and third I will explain a
little bit more in depth about live
operation and how you would want to do
operations in that local country and
lastly we will tell you about what you
can use from Google's tools to make this
more easier for you these are seasonings
images of seasoning sold in Southeast
Asian market so if you want to casually
cook for yourself what I've like exotic
dishes you can just follow the recipe
and put everything that they tell you to
do but if you want to be a cook if we
want to sell your dish you really have
to understand the ingredient that goes
with it so in this part I will tell you
about a little bit of facts and some of
the insights of the a pipe market and
before you we move on to that before
knowing what is out there you have to
know your intentions what is your
priority what's more important to is it
revenue or is it installed this makes
difference in which countries that you
will want to focus first for Japan and
Korea it's
a country with a lot of revenue and
great number of installs but the cost of
marketing is very high contrary to that
Southeast Asia its it has huge install
potential and the cost of marketing is
slow so if your priority is clearly on
the either side check it's an easy
decision you can make but if you want to
go to everywhere try Taiwan and Hong
Kong they have users with high AR ppu
average spending per spending users and
they're very much loyal so if you want
to test out your service or game these
markets could be a good place to start
with now when we talk about southeast
asia market we're talking about this six
key market Singapore Thailand Malaysia
Indonesia Philippines and Vietnam and we
talked about installs but they do make a
sizeable revenue in Indonesia
Philippines and Vietnam and since we
have the map I did a little dot throwing
across of what type of game category
works best in each region and it's it
was interesting because on the northern
side of these countries we see hardcore
RPGs doing really well on the blow we
see more of a diverse type of scheme
doing well this could be due to several
reasons it could be due to the device
performance but this is how it is and
the other thing that I've tried doing
was to color based on what messenger
platform works best for each region I
thought I will see some dominant color
but it betrayed mean there's a lot of
diverse colors in this map which means
if you want to use the best out of each
platforms you may have to think about
having strategies for each market
multiple builds
but we have preferred play game service
and Google sign-in that you can use in
all these countries so if you want to
scale your business you can use our
social logins and prepare your app from
the start material design works well
prepare to have your strap strings
separated so that you could easily
update and system elements are really
different among these countries and if
you haven't taken them out users might
feel the service foreign few examples
material design Asian users are already
very much educated in how the material
design is at how Android 4 factors play
in so you don't have to teach the users
how to use app if you use basic
structure of the material design and I
told you about separating the app
strings because language is all
different even for Taiwan and Hong Kong
they use traditional Chinese but if you
want to have voice control if you have
audio content they speak the different
chinese cantonese and mandarin in
indonesia bahasa works really well if
you want to pick up the performance and
on the system elements side if a dating
app asked me I'm born and raised in
Korea and they asked me how tall are you
in feet and inches I can't answer
because I don't know I know that I'm
hundred and sixty-seven centimeters high
but I don't know it in feet so if you
give that to Asian users what you are
most used to in us that doesn't work
that way so please we prepare that the
units will be different also same with
the days now we touch the brief about
ingredients you can always learn more on
yourself so let's talk about the cooking
localization so when it comes to
localization we say that it is a process
for those who are
starting to localize if you're already
an expert just go dive into it but if
you're starting to do a localization
this could be in a process so start
simple just try using Auto translation
in your app description because just by
doing that is opening your front door to
the new users and inviting them to come
in and if you think you see some actions
or responses from that market now you
can start getting more serious let them
know that you are starting to care for
them in their market by translating your
app and in the third phase you have to
really go in and operate in local
language in a native voice in the Play
Store you can localize the trailer icon
title description and key images and
this may sound easy or this may sound
very difficult to solve you but there
are developers who do it in a perfection
this is Polaris Office from Korea and
they're a promotional screen in Japan my
Japan colleague Evan right over there he
told me that it's hard for Japanese to
even think about that this app is not
from Japanese developer because they
reached to a point of perfection if you
see in the image they show the examples
within the app in Japanese and that sort
of detail can lead users to feel more
attached to the service and on the
capacity they not only localize the
store listings in the language they
localize with the local food content so
they will show the food that the local
users would mostly most love if you want
to see the impact 1password I've worked
with the team it's Canadian teams I love
the team and it only took them two weeks
to finish up their localization because
they had it ready in their ass
strings and right after that they saw a
hundred percent increase in install and
Korean market I think this is something
that is that is easy for you to make
decision on but not all services are
utility or it's simple but just think
that how much potential it brings once
you just start localizing so when to
choose between single and multiple
builds if your app is targeting more too
we saw the social services with more the
specific market service you should think
about building multiple bills but then
it means more resources engineering
resources needed for you that but the
service and the content will be much
more tailored to local users if you want
to keep a scale of it single build is
your answer and even within the single
bill you can still localize the business
model the alarm clock f they have a lot
of it of items they place the strategy
differently among the regions so for
example in Japan they have 35 paid items
in contrary to Southeast Asian markets
they only have 15 but the ads frequency
is very high in that market so balanced
up your monetization strategy based on
the country and subtalar pricing works
we have enabled sub dollar pricing in 18
countries in Google Play and in those
countries I told told you about the
economy and the purchasing power of each
country and in some of the countries one
dollar doesn't mean a single item it
means like your days way so in that
country's lower your prices and then you
you not only get more revenue you get
more engaging users and if you're
interested on earning money and play we
have a session prepared nine a.m.
tomorrow morning it's early I know
oh it's the last day but this is worth
your time please go in check out okay so
you have understood the market you have
your app ready in imperfect localization
now well it's what's your next step what
do you have to do you now you have to
really dive into that sea to that ocean
with a high tide operate your app with
the local voice so dominations by nexon
they communicate with users in japanese
when they leave response in the reviews
and coming back to the mixes case on
live operation let me give you a little
more detail about what they did so on
the first round of collaboration with
Evangelion they had three four
characters into the balls which is the
key of the game and they created four
stages that reflect the world in the
animation and they saw the
record-breaking high number of user who
simultaneously play the game which is
important for collaborative play games
and on the second round they did it
after six months they even saw more
higher engagement with unused the record
was broken again and this is how you Inc
start engaging users back to your
service even you've already have a
collaboration again and one other thing
is I did this with my Korean developers
together in Taiwan there was a trend
sometimes some of you may know this
already so like woman was stand at the
back of the wall with her back and the
guy will be hitting the wall protecting
or like getting onto the woman and the
hitting the law work wall was like a
buzzword in Taiwan and Korean developers
caught this and they create an inner
item especially for Taiwan market
and the result users loved it they saw
two times more install just right after
launching these new innovative and
equity sometimes acquisition really
helps cook pad acquired a lot of
communities and startups in recipe and
the cook service content business and it
was what one of the most effective way
of expanding their boundaries so quickly
and taking users from that countries
this is the case from that marbles
future fight when they went into Taiwan
they did the marketing that works in
that region so they mobile you a TBC
wrapping bus which probably isn't
familiar to many of you and they did a
lot of consumer exhibition and events to
engage with more with the users they
invested this case is evil main when the
marble you could also collaborate with
local celebrities or local influencers
in that way users feel that through the
local celebrate its image that game or
app service is more relevant to you
alarm on did a really creative CPG
collaboration with a juice bottle they
had a QR code in the juice leading to
the website where it showed about the
the app and after this they saw two
times the growth in that market by now I
hope you have the chance to think about
what you could start trying and what you
can implement in your market let me tell
you about the Google tools with your at
the first stage of going global use the
APK translation service in our developer
console it is not a perfect quality but
it is good enough for the local eyes and
we recently announced that if you have a
local pricing we now round up the
currency to
thing that makes more sense in the local
market and you can price it in a way
that you want but the thing you have to
keep in mind is always launch test and
iterate the process to see what really
works for your region and you can do
this through analyzing the users in
conversion funnel in the developer
console now you can see by the countries
which country had the most install in
the conversion rate of that country was
how much and you can also analyze the
ratings by the country and understand
what is wrong with certain countries
even we translate the feedbacks for you
in your language in a case that I want
to share is create a bomb spo2 it's a
very pretty pink dolphin kids are lovely
but one day they saw a huge drop in user
rating in Philippines that is after they
launched and one of the user feedback
was that photo meet meant something bad
in Philippines so they took the response
from that review and change the name to
pro 2 and after that they're doing good
grade in Philippines and do a lot of
store listing experiments you can a be
test your icons your apt description
your trailers tell you a case about
monster strikes international expansion
they tested their icon this is the
winner they also tested the app
descriptions like the key description
messages and they tested the screenshot
and the video in a way they plan to see
the maximum effort and after this they
saw sixty percent increase in conversion
before and after the test and in a world
where the marketing cost and cost per
install is going higher and higher
improving the conversion rate is really
critical for the business and then
afterwards they start testing
the in-app experiences if you want to
know more about game side and about how
to be more successful in Google Play you
have a session tomorrow 10am so try not
miss it again and we have I show you
some examples from that marble we have
net marbles Duke coming in to speak for
the event so you will be able to hear
more about the examples that he can give
okay so kind of wrapping all the things
that I discuss I'll share to success
cases from developers and this will kind
of help you to organize what we have
discussed today Joey cities game of dice
was success in Hong Kong remember do you
remember that I said you have to plan
ahead of your strategy that game of dice
planned the localization strategy before
they launch so they had a team who could
best localize in the local language by
including traditional Chinese speaker
and simplified Chinese speaker and
having a check and balance process
within the localization team and then
they would check the localization level
with the Korean team in a processed way
so that they don't miss out a single
word and the lie boss they collaborated
with celebrity that's the very popular
in hong kong market and they
collaborated with YouTube creators to
let the game know in a more familiar way
to users but the importance of a/b
testing is here they thought celebrating
icons would work better than the game
character image icon but when they
tested it actually the game character
image worked better in performance so
you have to test an area to see what
works best for you they did marketing
that makes sense in the local markets
they create webtoons
in the subway they created engaging
videos that explain of the gameplay and
they wrapped buses and I will show you
the music's matches win in Japan so true
therm is honestly the BDS like us we
thought Chaplin market is almost
impossible to crack in terms of service
or content from developers abroad but
musics match did it they localize they
even localize the experience for
Japanese users and what they saw is
three hundred percent increase and they
was ranked number one in music category
in Japan what they did was they
personalized to Japanese users localize
deeply of the all the things that they
can localize in play and they did a lot
of a be testing did an analytics from
the developer console and really worked
with the local market experts on the FG
is and learning more and more of the
local market I told you in the opening
session how Google Play is the magical
door and the door is open for all of you
is open for everyone who wants to go and
dive in to a new market we will keep
listening to the feedbacks that you have
and difficulties that you had going into
the global market and we will make the
product better and better for you you
already have a better product that
announced this time with more countries
that you can test your a be testing on
simultaneously and of the price charming
price roundings that we provide so keep
trying and let us know what works and
what doesn't and we'll we'll try our
best to be better platform for you to
if you have any questions you can update
on the spaces and since I have five
minutes left I may be able to take one
or two questions from the audience the
mic is in the center if you have a
question you can do this and I will have
my friend Speedy's from other regions
raise your hands pure be4 Korea there's
there's people who are part of in
responsible for these APEC markets if
you want to connect with us more find us
we'll be here thank you for listening